[Applaudissements]
tiens susan est ce que vous arrivez
sextoys là-bas des sex toys non j'en ai
plus vous avez tous vendus sur ebay
[Rires]
avant j'en avais même castaldi lui
citoyen né à la maison on disait c'est
vrai benhalima la des boulettes vibrant
à aa
aujourd'hui demain l'entière abassi même
où je les collectionne les yeux prennent
de la valeur
d'accord vous voyez aller à l'époque
voyez comme quoi ça a évolué à l'époque
lionel cassan qui portent en effet que
la 2 où il avait montré un sextoy il a
été mis à pied pendant trois semaines
ouais alors voyez comme quoi quelque
part on a évalué un tout petit peu merci
bernard toi tu y es tu manques c'est
pourquoi dieu donne durant l'émission
partout où il va